so Oliver's dad is Kurt Russell and
stepdad
his mom's Golding right so you're
surprisingly normal yeah like I talked
to Goldie Hawn on on FaceTime and she
was like the kindest lady ever I had to
give them because I it was freaking me
out
yeah I'm at the same way I can't meet
yeah I can't because I'm a dirty I'm
from the Comedy Store yeah yeah you know
even when like big comics show up I kind
of just like you know if Chris Rock and
Bilborough are talking in the parking
lot I'll back away and then go somewhere
else
I know right I know you know what's so
interesting you say that is because I
I've been I just feel like I'm still
that dirtbag to so even now as I'm
selling like now I'm finally moving
tickets and I'm like oh yeah yeah you
have me now almost detach yourself
because like when I did Brea I did pray
uh and it's a 600 seat room right
Saturday I sold up Oh show that's crazy
right and I'm in I'm in the back and I'm
going and I see all the people and I'm
like freaking out I was like I don't
wanna do it so when you when you hear
your name you kind of almost like you
snap out of this like me me me yeah yeah
and then you actually just have to do
the job of course you go out there and
you're like all right and then you just
go into it's like when you've done a TV
spot before right yeah the how
nerve-wracking is that yeah first time
you do well here's the thing though is I
have to the thing with comedy me is that
I'm I like to fight
right and for me those years of like
doing those dinner audiences who didn't
give a [ __ ] in a mall right those $1500
weeks you're gonna love me after
yeah that thing yeah now that my fists
are down I'm kind of like oh wait oh
okay I guess I have to go into this
differently yeah but I'm still angry
inside which is good you and I are
similar in that way what do you think
that is trauma in childhood yeah hundred
percent
it's that disapproval approval thing you
know I was immigrant too my parents are
Hungarian and they grew up in communist
all that [ __ ] right not getting
unconditional love I think that's the
secret yeah I got love but I got
violence too
I don't know exactly what it did to me
but I know that some of my behaviors
right just in my life is rooted and
that's why I won't go to therapy be how
you have to why dying for you to go I
know you guys have a number for me
I am dying for you to go I did I think
it would be bad yeah tell him why I it's
just a place to unload and process
without the judgment of anyone I mean
even though we have partners and people
that we love you know they're just
sometimes they're not the place you want
to put your things on alright cuz you're
not qualified yeah and you know they're
able to help you kind of get through
things in a way that none of your
friends are gonna be able to do you know
make you happier yeah well and honestly
I do feel lighter when I walk out right
yeah I don't have the greatest therapist
he's a chill guy you should probably get
the greatest guy but you you know what's
so funny because you have said I asked
you and Tom I know and then a people on
my shows have said it like you need to
go yeah right
because I have issues there too now I'm
not I don't act out but there is a thing
and they can see that treat myself so
poorly like if I mess up on a line you
know I mean like it's so hard on myself
yeah and then like also when the
pressure is there I just I'm disappear
what do you mean you disappear
disassociate know what happens is like a
table reads I'll like everyone will sit
down the network and everyone will sit
down until everyone sat down I don't go
in the room because I don't want to have
the small talk because I did that once
where you sit there and the president of
Warner Brothers so was your weekend
yeah all right go into a story that like
I think I'm a part and it's too much
like I don't know it's weird cuz I I got
molested by a guy with Down syndrome
when I was a young man and then I don't
you know I mean and you say things yeah
as if you're around you know other
comedians yes that's my problem is I
think I'm a space alien and the other
people yeah that's why I'm friends with
all comics ya know we all speak the same
language and there's no judgment but
sometimes we're exposed to the real
people yeah do you want to be right
we're real people but yeah but then you
say something that's gonna like [ __ ] up
you know me your relationship with them
yeah I don't mean real people like like
yeah but like I perceive them to be more
together than yeah yeah and it's yeah
[Music]